if anyone has the goods on Donald Trump
it's his former personal attorney
Michael Cohen I've said this before
Cohen's been convicted Cohen is heading
to prison for what is as of now
scheduled to be a three-year term that
is set to start in the first eight or
nine days or so of March and he was
going to testify publicly before a House
committee in just about a couple of
weeks on February 7th and we've been
anxiously awaiting this testimony I want
to hear from Michael Cohen because we
could hear all sorts of potentially huge
and relevant statements made by him but
that testimony has unfortunately been
postponed by Michael Cohen indefinitely
which to me means cancelled when someone
says something is postponed indefinitely
I'm hearing that it's cancelled and he
says the reason why is because of the
threats from President Trump and from
president Trump's TV attorney Rudy
Giuliani and how his family particularly
his father-in-law and his wife are now
very very much afraid as a result of the
threats that have been issued so the
Rudy Giuliani piece is getting to be a
bigger and bigger factor in everything
that's going on in the media circus
right now and we're going to sort of
focus in on that a little bit later but
for now let's keep it focused on the
Cohen allegations we got a statement
from longtime Clinton friend and Michael
Cohen's attorney remember Magga is
making attorneys get attorneys Lanny
Davis put out a statement about this
decision saying quote due to ongoing
threats against this family from
president Trump and mr. Giuliani as
recently as this weekend as well as mr.
Cohen's continued cooperation with
ongoing investigations by advice of
counsel mr. Cohen's appearance will be
postponed to a later date mr. Cohen
wishes to thank chairman Cummings for
allowing him to appear before the House
Oversight Committee and looks forward to
testifying at the appropriate time this
is a time where mr. Cohen had to put his
family and their safety first so now
we'll get to the threats in a second
House Democrats now have a decision to
make they could say okay we're just not
going to hear from Michael Cohen for the
time being or they could subpoena
Michael Cohen to force him to
be there and some Democrats have already
said they fully expect Oversight
Committee Chairman Elijah Cummings to
indeed issue a subpoena and to get
Michael Cohen there before his early
March report to prison date we'll see if
that happens but let's go through a few
other elements of this first of all what
threats are they alleging Trump and
Giuliani made because there's two sides
to this publicly Donald Trump has
started talking about Michael Cohen's
father-in-law intimating that he may be
a criminal that he may be sort of a mob
type guy you then had Rudy Giuliani
answer questions about whether it's
appropriate for Donald Trump to be doing
that for whether it's appropriate for
the president to be suggesting the
family members of someone involved in an
investigation like this be targeted for
possible criminal wrongdoing although
that's all it is at this point Rudy
Giuliani said well if they're criminals
then it is completely and totally
appropriate so that may be the full
extent of the threats that Michael Cohen
is referring to which are already very
very bad I mean that even that is
completely out of this world for a
president who is under an investigation
that is unprecedented other than maybe
what we saw happen during Richard
Nixon's presidency start to imply that
Michael Cohen had better be careful
about what he says because next thing
you know his father-in-law might be
under investigation so that is all
already outrageous then the question is
have there also been private threats
made have there been private threats
communicated to Michael Cohen because if
Rudy Giuliani already says it's possible
Trump spoke to Cohen about the testimony
as some kind of general thing of course
denying that any kind of direction till
I was made it's certainly conceivable
that during that same conversation there
could have been implicit or explicit
threats made as well remember that it is
very very likely that even if Cohen did
testify he wouldn't testify publicly
about any of the real bombshells that we
don't yet know about so maybe what
happened here Pat is that Michael Cohen
calculated that the upside to this
public testimony
is just not that big compared to the
negative attention and the risks and I
don't know about you Pat but if I were
in his position I would be wondering the
same thing how much can i really say in
this testimony and the last thing I want
is my wife's dad to end up under
investigation here well president Trump
says that Michael Cohen has only been
threatened with the truth which seems to
give a little bit of credence to this
whole thing
the only thing that gives me pause about
this story is how involved Rudy Giuliani
is like we know Giuliani to be Trump's
TV lawyer he's not representing him in
court he just kind of goes out there on
these cable shows and beta tests these
different defenses of Trump so I'd kind
of be surprised to hear that he was
directly influencing Trump's enemies and
trying to threaten them yeah I think the
most likely scenario is that what he's
referring to when he talks about Rudy
Giuliani is Giuliani on TV simply saying
no I don't think there's anything that
crazy about Trump suggesting maybe that
there should be an investigation into
Cohen's father-in-law and it's possible
that Trump and Giuliani have been
putting pressure on Cohen in some other
ways that don't constitute threats and
that then that combined with the public
statements just kind of rose to a level
where Cohen said he's bailing and then
the legal question is would any of that
including what was said publicly by
Trump and Giuliani is that witness
intimidation witness tampering is it a
possible obstruction of justice those
would be crimes and the trend here is by
Trump it's been the same trend for a
long time which is obstruct any way that
you can influence influence witnesses
any way that you can behave like the mob
guy he sort of is implying Michael
Cohen's father-in-law is we don't yet
have confirmation of direct threats
beyond what was said publicly but this
is all part and parcel of this long-term
trend of criminal mobster behavior that
we've come to see and expect from Donald
Trump and then we really have to talk
about what's going on with Rudy Giuliani
even above and beyond this particular
story and that's that's where I want to
go next today's show was made possible
in part by better help.com slash Pakman
better help is a service that gives you
unlimited remote access to your own
fully licensed therapist by way of phone
video and text it's less expensive than
physically going to see a therapist in
an office and you don't need to have
insurance to use better help and they
stand behind what they do better help
has a no-questions-asked full money-back
guarantee if you're not satisfied with
your experience all of better helps
counselors are thoroughly vetted for
accreditation and experience it's all
spelled out in their Terms of Service
better help requires all of its
counselors to be fully trained and
licensed and they must have at least
three years and 2,000 hours of
counseling experience so you know that
your counselor is qualified to help you
but if you don't think your counselor is
the right fit for you better help makes
it easy to switch to a new one if you've
been thinking about getting involved
with a therapist you should really check
out better help just click the link
underneath this video